in Mexican miracle news oh [ __ ] always
like a pinata surprise
yep submitted by procrastinating as
always
oh my like college student anymore
actually a Mexican baby is believed to
perform miracles eighty-four years after
his death so isn't that a Mexican
grandpa it's a baby a baby how's the
baby miracles because I need to know
this because I believe that a lot of
Hispanic people believe in a lot of
mysticism so I want to know dude what
the [ __ ] you say be alright root girl
like the surf Korea know through with a
bruja isn't that witchcraft okay
blueheart be real okay
hurry ya know cuz it keeps changing to
the what's that something really I was
thinking which store oh yeah does it
make sense as to why you changed it to
Bruno Marty a pizzeria
this little boy eyes name is Raul Raul
Ito Gonzalez now little ya know Victoria
if Alana
Eleazar brow yes Rito me
you know gotta roll it roll it off
aggressive arts yeah so he died said he
was born April 2nd 1932 he died 10
months later on February 2nd 1993 1933
sorry and uh and so now now he's like
super famous in the area which is near
Acapulco in Mexico and it all started
because back in 2007 in June of 2007
this woman arrived at the cemetery with
her young dying daughter in her arms and
she asked the groundskeeper where like
to point her in the direction of a tomb
of a child whose grave has been
forgotten by his parents or her parents
and so this great groundskeeper pointed
her to delete those tomb which was just
deserted no one knows no flowers no
nothing and so she spent about an hour
ago right off the bat this is a
groundskeeper so he's keeping childlike
oh yeah the baby I would visit that ring
because he has to throw away the flowers
and throw away goes yeah for the last
five years no one visited that that that
statue or whatever yeah that dead bed
over there no one cares yeah and so she
went over and she spent an hour and a
half
praying with her daughter who doctors
said would not live to the end of that
day so they did the mucker addendum
execute well they weren't mixed I mean
they're speaking Spanish aren't they
like from Argentina or laughing Sheila
how do you actually pronounce it there's
not a G there is a G did you say it
again
okay I know but you don't pronounce the
G no it's a head it's a head so my name
would be Hale vana it's a hub Hey
yeah bottom there saying that the title
the song comes from a neighborhood in
Spain it's something I just knew it
wasn't Mexican oh so pretty much the
manga the Macarena on the tube and then
what happened the Mexican prayer isn't
it
you don't say that G in Argentines nope
no like Jorge
that's Jane Irma you only pronounce the
G if it starts like Gustavo right if it
starts with Najimy no does that one of
them and then like I don't know the Y's
Gustavo or goose do you mind even be
like the Jews
anyway see what yellow then what is Paul
why Emma I don't know shit's [ __ ] up I
don't love you maybe
whyever i know then wouldn't it be I
don't know your name is hell vada hey
hold on oh you know what Hale means in
[ __ ] Vietnamese hey Hale means like
Pig I hope that's my astrological sodium
no no the value yes that was no one here
boy boar yes you're a pest intelligent
and very smelly
well boars are really smart but they're
a pest yes
what are you I'm a rat I knew so after
the woman's finish praying to the lead
though she promised out Lisa like if her
daughter would survive that she would
return to give thanks to him and like
you know said of his Jamal nice oh and
in nearly two months later the lady
returned with her daughter who had fully
recovered Wow yeah she gave she brought
her lethal flowers if I got toys sweep
to thank him and then her story quickly
spread
I was in the Macarena there though
yeah and then then the and then another
miracle and I really got popular was
that there was this man who he was
driving in his truck he was like a city
worker and he ended up getting he lost
control of his truck and because his
brakes failed oh I thought he just
[ __ ] let go and it stuck he calls for
Nolita here's a girl eat up while this
car is [ __ ] going crazy bad terrain
it's not just putting his hands on the
steering wheel
ya know yeah so you're just calling for
Talitha and immediately miraculously got
control of his vehicle at that exact
same moment and then after after he
survived that whole ordeal he went back
to his tomb and fixed it all up and
payment and just made it really didn't
know what to hispanic people know that
10 month olds are basically debilitated
they can't do nothing don't take away we
think they're all intelligent because
how was this ten month old going to as a
ghost I think one thing I never
understood of Catholicism it is and this
is just me just not being very Catholic
uh but I just one thing I just never
understood was if we have God and he's
kind of like the omniscient the
omnipotent all of that write your own
[ __ ] word that a strong Nishant
what's omniscience that is everywhere
that he's everywhere all at once Misha I
know omnipotent yeah that's that's
all-knowing isn't it I don't [ __ ]
know maybe nepeta yeah I know I bet you
said it was omniscient I never heard
that it's a new perfume by Calvin Klein
yeah this is that you're everywhere all
at once yeah your every role at once
yeah so that's like he's all-powerful
and he's everywhere at once like for me
at least I even questioned this with my
mom I'm like why are we pranked two
other same see stuff was in the Bible to
not worship on her I don't I don't get
it it yeah that was the one cut I think
I didn't understand about Catholicism
because there is that that rule like you
don't pray to other idols but didn't you
have Maria right who she is not a god
but people pray the Virgin Mary we have
a we have a seat for everything there's
a saint for that rugby ISM their stake
forward like if you lose something for
death like like their st. Peter rethink
everything
what's that deals Dale's dealt the end
of those martyrs
yeah you should watch cocoa and explain
I'm going to watch it this Saturday like
a beta Det yeah and they paint the sugar
skulls so thanks to cocoa I learned what
the whole thing is about because I never
knew what the Mexican celebrating the
dead or something so pretty much what
they believe or according to cocoa is
that they saw our ancestors we gotta
keep remembering them and like lay out
petals for them to come from the spirit
realm to visit us on that day in on
earth and like and then you give them
things that they liked when they were
alive so then they get to enjoy in the
spirit realm
yeah and it's a social occasion people
will go yeah they'll go and try cemetery
and like they'll have like a picnic or
whatever I mean it's rented it's at
nighttime but yeah oh yeah yeah and then
like you just you're there and you're
just like you're just treating it as if
like they're there with YouTube just you
can treat them like they they're there
okay how about one Asian culture where
they like dig up the corpse [ __ ] you
know we're talking about on you they
literally dig up the corpses in
Madagascar right now they're getting
this like spread I forgot what it was
but because of them digging up their
dead no no disease they're getting the
plague I think it is all or something
crazy
I forgot leave that [ __ ] alone
yeah he's part of the tradition black
plague is being not the tradition I'm
good I know it's a baby but I picture
chancho from the from naturally nacho
libre I pictured
so you told me you never wrestled away I
pictured him flying in to the rescue and
helping everybody out and blessing
people you know after reading this story
I started thinking like is there a baby
in all Mexican cemeteries because when I
went to Mexico with Casey's parents we
went to go do a night tour of a cemetery
that's really famous in the area
you guys are nuts and anime they pointed
out a tomb of a kid a little boy that
same thing like healed pretty he'll do
miracles for me when I go and give them
toys and stuff and like that he shares
with like other little kids that go and
like kids like three-year-olds
two-year-olds will go to his tomb on
their own and like go talk to him
like that's crazy that's what they say
in the tour I don't know but yeah so
they're now they're saying that people
visit probably thought every single day
about 10 to 15 people are always
visiting him and then on April 2nd which
is really those birthday and on November
1st which is the All Saints Day is the
number of visitors reaches about a
hundred or more looks like a birthday
cake whatever makes people happy and
then they're met there remembering him
yeah gives people fake me I've come
across as like a gangster lay into it
because while Leto is it tasted Rolly
though is Ito like you add at the end
because it's like little that's cool
still surprised that Argentina is not
pronounce Argentina
not oh you know the Wieland Germany is
not even like hey Lenny or something
it's only money
Alima Aleman yeah yeah what's that mean
it means Germany Alemannia Alemannia why
and if you're German you're a layman
Aleman how do you spell Alemannia hey al
am i earning money how do you say okay
me and Chinese dog or dog walk what we
do that's Dutch right yeah i do / oh
that makes sense
doosh doosh lane yes it's interesting
though countries call other countries
and other languages because it depends
on when it was translated yeah so when
it was Deutsch then it was double but
now it's Germany so it's like it they're
all kind of off yes interesting maybe it
was a Aleman Kingdom